[音楽]
表紙がありますタイマー証拠証言や財産分割言うか申します映画白い検定裸なお仕事を
しておりますけれども
さてそしてくるんですけど皆さん
言えん
n どうなんだろうかということを考えあったことは良いでしょうか
まあ今時です願っての先生は芸待てばもて笑っ思っていればシャープのシェア
コンプレックス一体ですかね
近所の tsutaya とカレンダーショップ行けば如何メールとか見れるしたいな
んですけれどもそんな中でへ方は何かっていうことを考えられた方もちょっと変わっ
てるかもしれないっていう風な悪寒が完成なんかもしれません
けれども映画非常というのはそのちょっと変わったことですね
審決それでやってる osho たんだというふうに思っていただければ幸いです
まあ私たちはどうして英語とは何だろうかなんてことを考えてい
その理由が鋭利なというものはそして披露ゲイ作品というものは私たちの生活にとって
なくてはならないものそういう考えがあるんですね
同期て私たちにとって映画そしてゲイ作品主張なんかそのことを今日話したいと思って
います
ではえーよとは何だろうかということについて過去にですねいろんな人がいろんなこと
を言ってなキャンプして
[音楽]
日浅たんですか
とも銀次っそくよ世界の際創造 t がどうしましたちょっと難しいことなんですけど
これはどういうことかというと a のというものは人
心ない氏は社会にとっての真実を吐き出す道具だとこのような考え方をしたんですね
などを探して正解かもしれない正解かを知らないがどうか号に生きた感がないという気
がする
というのは理学有名な話を知るだけではないっていう気がするからです
ましてや昨今はですねいわゆるポストするその事態
真実というな人にとってさまざまで何が真実かわかんないしなかった場合
そんな中においてひょっとは何かといっぱいしてから来ないんですよね
まあそれが真実なのということはなかなか通用しないつまりこの言葉何か乗り越え
なきゃいけないそういった加害なってないけど
ニッセン例えばなんですけれども人間が共鳴食べ歩いてしまう映画把握しました
まあ作品名は申し上げませんけれどもなんとか早く丁寧な
その何ともなくてが人間が脅威かであるとする
非常に精巧に作られたコンピューターが何かがにゃんですけれども
園田 rain か computer graphic なる10処分はどこにある
か
生死すらない
わけなんですが要するにそれはコンピュータがなくなるっていうは取って人間を教育
変わるわけないじゃんマッスルさせるわけないじゃんかといいですね
数キロで適当な理由に過ぎないそういう意味じゃねえよ here コンピューター
デー
した監督はどういい歌感がない
あるいはわー
ちゃんとガールという頃襟が市場の五輪を終えていニラ
監督ですルールっていう美術の世界です聞いたことは名前かも知れませんその印象派の
絵画の選択として徴兵な大ミス止めは息子さんなんですけども
ジャンルモールディングなんとこははいっ
スクリーンの上に映像にはそれはもう全て a型
を押してい
なるほど比べフィルムときますねピントプールんだがしかし今現在においては必ず死を
スクリーンのメリットが映像が流れるのが芸がではないと言いますのテレビはも丈夫な
んですが
遊ぶんそれからタブレット聞いてはスマートフォンでを a が命を絶って行かない人
だって最近はして会おうとすると待ってましたねそれが起きるという風になれば
スクリーンと覚えている方がどうだシート思えない
数人示野伝えのウィンド物価でっかいかまわんですねあれたしたりスクリーンレースと
映像が動いているんですけれども
あれをエイラートだなんとなーく高抵抗感がある
雪もいたしますあんならばこれもノート
もう一つ日た感がない
ずっとじゃあ過ぎにですねどんな言葉がありえるか私の一番ですね
あこれはなるほどそうかもしれないなと思った言葉があります
それがええああいう写真は無茶な患者がちょっと読みたくないでめんどくさいですね
の端を見ますけれどもこれは統一のエア韓国ヴィムヴェンダースというですね
監督の言った言葉なんですけれども真ん中なって欲しいことを書いていますがこれは
どういうことかというと
2枚写真があったらその写真と写真の間に時間が経過している
一んならばそこにを通した物語があえて組んであるな
それはゲームではないか
このような髪型なんです
なるほどこれならちょっときいてくるなぁと私は思いました
なので私がたまたまですねそのと中に入って写真を撮るとともに近所で工事現場だった
ので年をとってまいりました
とまあこう重視ですね血迷ってこれを10分ではすごいか言ってですね写真を撮りまし
た
ちょっと間違え探しみたいに見えるおっしゃるけどこの2枚の間には明らかな差がある
というのは
例えばこの糸
いなくなっているしですねこの人はこっちに移動しているというような形で
写真動いていないがこれが日本あればすごいほぼた猪木冷気が
というのは例えば声でなくなっちゃったけどもしかしたらちょっと休憩取ってまぁどっ
か行ったの部屋た通すというかも知れあるいは
家には市長と餃子ん用意買えないかも知れて大きさおごられるかもしれない
そのようなものまでの計105に生まれているかもしれないですね
ということをた知事は想像することができるのです
映画でがあるという風に考えならばそれをなくぼ
確かになってこれ中かもしれない
とっいうことを考えるとあのー
2枚ので
あればそれはゲームのではないかこれが一つ
大きな会社だと思います
する事ないと映画というのは最近はデジタル撮影会って来ましたからこれが銘柄通用し
なくなってきていますけど
つーかちょっとで打つ打っている
で1秒映画のフィルムては24コマなります
そして映画も上映時間が120分あるとすると全部17万1000張って困る
結構な情報量ですねこの情報上お腹に
味が考える
いや電話さん対するその情報こそでいいかというのではないんだ
ということですね
であるならばその情報中からそのメッセージをリトルというその心の動き
それを映画館初代作品鑑賞たようではないか
これが一つの私が考える映画という定義です
リッ
当時で込めること私が考え始めた下級そのきっかけとなることはですね
まさにここなんです映画というものが持って今
圧倒的な情報量
することを最初に黄瀬がされたのは私が小学校6年生の時に
スティーブンスピルバーグ監督も民主党もそう思って
んですか
この作品は本当に1中年男性はですね
家放尿低減しを体験している神その痕跡を追いかけているうちに鮭
宇宙からやってきた未知の生命体と出会いそして彼らと思うんですよ
そういった物語
でそのクライマックスましたに銀卵このカーセットと思うんですねまさかもシャンティ
&ように
巨大な宇宙船がそのから飛来してくる
そしてその左してきた宇宙船の中からたくさんの宇宙人たちが上がっていく
人類はそうやってきた初めて見る夢中彼の生命体と接してそれに入っ
胸郭の思いを寄せるそういったくらい楽になるんですけどこれはビックリしました
本当にその馬名がですね
通り変なん豪華な美術館そしてそれを彩る圧倒的な音楽である
そして人類が初めて未知の生命ないと出会ってそして
分かると
物語がそこにあった砂その分価格です
でそれはどういうことかというと映画というのは
美術音楽文学その双眸と上げてきているその3つの映画ジャベールというものは持って
いるすべてのケースじゃんと同時に体験することは new
そんな映画の余韻と a が多い店や技術
存在し得ない
ということを
おおーんなんです
このとんでもないような目でしまった
でも食べなよどーにゃ体験を他に伝えなければいいんじゃない
それが私なり外食の
子が好きかありました
酒席ほどですね人間の写真があればそこにをもずと動きが生まれるというふうに
申し上げました
この龍玄たーーーーステージとのとは団体やんですけれども
[音楽]
こうですねー
なんで写真が2万円あればそこにも度が太陽モデルがその来られる理由する
宮崎駿というですねということで風の谷のナウシカということだけど
映画監督は
このように調理
ようなものはすべて動いている
のん
[音楽]
ブービー者ヒアリング
そうするとそこには勝たず空中の光が
z に何が変わっている先ほどのこういうゲームをしながらまさにそうでした
それはなぜそんなことが起こるのか
それは当然地球が回っているからです
地球が持っている限り必ず首低下が
ということはその動きと動きの境目に
ものが手にもらわれる景気が底がこのような事件である
ということになるわけです
ではどうして夜中の方は動いているかということを
皆さんに私たちはこの地球上にしているからそういうことを考えると
ものがたいというのが
家中がちょっとこうてくるがない限りは必ずそこにパリで開く生まれてくるんだろう
こういった考え方ってなったけど
きらん形で
と言うんですねそうやっているだろうかと
広々ポロという酒を飲んでいいですねかけの所という作品を作るために
17分甘いものでを書きまし
それが101分の上位法が堅牢な100円強のジャージがございます
1秒換算すると平均28枚
それはもう凄い情報よう求められているわけですね
でこれ言葉労働を宮崎監督
映画という中で物語来たために早漏でほしいんですけども
私たちがなぜ経過が必要なのかという最初の通りに戻る時だしたことをといたします
色まで話を走ってきたように映っている場合もやるか機関と思ってくればもう
オーダーになろうというおすすめに込めておりました
そしてそのローンタイプに触れるということが
官らが
発信しようとしてメッセージそれから考え方は私たちが受け取れるということです
そしてその食べ方に増えるということはその
私たちは彼らの労働でもに対してきれいずリスペクトを生み探すことができます
そして私の仕事に対するリスペクト
家留年というのは私たちがむず東1の部分対する思いやる気持ちを風景
そのように思います
私たち昨今ですね
よく
ますミュートないでいいです
いわゆる経済優先型の本当に息戦で琴の膣が来ていいものが悪く
許せないました学問においてもチン文学的なだけでもうちょっとごく一部ではあります
けれどもキースような子
ミニします
でもそれってどことなく他社の仕事に対する気合いを書いた考え方じゃないんだなって
いうふうに思うことだけ
でも私たちはそういった考え方にはくるしない
なぜかというと
私たちはこのように良い文学4名
そして良い絵画を知り良い音楽を聴いてそしてチェック素晴らしい映画を見るそれが
機密度北支部転がるんだからです
そして減税を切り次した知る心という
思うと世界に対する興味関心を指さしたてきます
私はそういうこと勉強に館てくることをしながら
5な地球は常に回っていると言いました私たちは地球上に今し球場に来ております
したがって世界一のし地球に関する対する興味関心になりところ私はチャッ切ることが
できません
で丸が見えに映画というのは阻止
記録ゲイ作品というのは私たちにとって必要なものだというふうに私は考えます
ぴ私たちがう
つまり私たち映画批評家9仕事というのはそういったことを皆さんを一人一人爪作品を
鑑賞する者たちがそのことに気づいていくなくたんだよ
さやか
お手伝いをしている辛くと私はすぐに考えて仕事をしています
先ほど申し上げ例えば民主党の裾部分ですとかと
でございましたそういった作品ですとかものすごい代行協力ですとか
ダイナ会があるいは長大な文学作品そういったものは5周年一重の大善戦しては作れ
ないかもしれないけれども
作品を鑑賞するということは1人心さえ持っていれば皆さん1言うという誰もが体験
することができる
であるだけに
技術が詰まっ大事なんじゃないかなってみんな氏は考えている
今日はクリスマスイブですね本当に米の反射させていただくためにとてもふさわしいだ
と思います
本当にこの皆さんご静聴ありがとうございましたメリークリスマス
[拍手]